but being no doubt I am the underdog
[Music]
circumstances
my message to the party and the country
is simple I have a plan to steer our
economy through these headwinds
we need a return to traditional
conservative economic values
[Music]
foreign
Minister that wants to reassure the
markets that Britain is being a sensible
economic player it's going to mean
jettisoning all of the supposed tax cuts
that the trust government had talked
about and it's going to mean uh almost
certainly Some Cuts in state spending to
try to balance these books and assure
the markets that the economy is in safe
hands and then of course try to take us
into election probably in 2024 and win
it rather than lose badly to the labor
party which is what current opinion
polls suggests would happen
Richie sunac 60
399 this truss 81
320 citizens